there's no expectation now that this
kyrgy's rescue team will find anyone
alive under the rubble of these
apartments in antaki
what they're trying to do is at least
give relatives a body to bury
Mehmet gular lost five members of his
family
it has been 14 days I'm waiting for my
aunt dead or alive
what matters is we get it from here so
we can bury her and give her a place
under the soil
Mehmet and is classified as missing
amidst the constantly updating
statistics on the tens of thousands of
dead or injured or homeless there's one
number the Turkish government can't
provide
it doesn't know how many people are
still missing
the scale of the disaster and the
expectations of the survivors takes its
toll on the more than 35
000 Turkish and foreign Rescuers working
here
we have psychologists in our team
offering support to help us get over
stress and depression I've never seen an
earthquake like this in my whole life
you have to shut down your emotions when
you do the job in antakia survivors have
access to food medicines and Tents but
the government wants somehow to start
rebuilding as soon as possible
at least 345 000 apartment buildings
have been destroyed according to the
Turkish government of course every one
of them somebody's home and now that the
Surge and rescue operation has
effectively ended the task of
demolishing and rebuilding his beginning
it may prove impossible to calculate
exactly how many people are missing or
dead following the earthquakes here
but in some places they know
every balloon here represents the life
of a child that lived in this apartment
building
Smith Al Jazeera and Takia